chaque fois que les combats dans une
nouvelle région en syrie au delà de ces
montagnes une nouvelle vague de réfugiés
vient gonfler la population de la vallée
de la bekaa au liban
rabia est l'un d'eux au départ sa femme
et ses quatre enfants non accompagnés
ici mais sa cadette souffre d'une
maladie chronique
incapable de payer les frais de ces
traitements médicaux au liban rabia a dû
renvoyer sa femme et trois de ses
enfants en syrie lui est resté derrière
avec un marc le plus vieux pour qui un
retour en syrie aurait été un arrêt de
mort dit son père c'est un garçon alors
s'ils y retournent
il sera forcé de se joindre à l'armée
dit-il vous savez c'est la guerre là-bas
amar ne risque donc pas de mourir sur la
ligne de front mais un autre danger le
guette
il est atteint d'un cancer un lymphome
de hodgkin
quand il a reçu son diagnostic il y a
quelques mois la famille a voulu de
nouveau se réunir au liban
trop tard depuis janvier dernier le
liban a mis en place une série de
mesures pour freiner le flot de réfugiés
syriens qui traversent la frontière
selon les chiffres officiels le liban
accueille au bas mot 1.2 millions de
syriens
il représente maintenant une personne
sur 5 de la population totale les
bureaux de haut commissariat aux
réfugiés de beyrouth grue toujours
d'activité mais depuis le mois de mai
dernier le gouvernement du liban
interdit aux nations unies d'enregistrer
tout nouveau cas de réfugiés sur son
territoire
les syriens qui se trouve déjà au liban
se plaignent de règles administratives
complexes et coûteuses qu'ils soient
enregistrés auprès de l'onu ou pas ils
doivent obtenir des papiers de résidence
de la sûreté générale du liban pour ce
faire il leur faut payer 200 dollars et
fournir une preuve notarié de logements
est souvent la garantie d'un parent
libanais entre autres conditions
ce n'est donc pas un hasard si amnistie
internationale a choisi le liban pour
dévoiler un rapport sur la crise
profonde provoquée par un nombre record
de réfugiés à l'échelle mondiale plus de
50 millions de personnes sont
aujourd'hui déracinés par les gays
ici le liban ne rencontre pas
entièrement ses obligations légales et
morales envers les réfugiés
l'échec nous appartient à tous de
l'organisme ce n'est pas aux pays
voisins des pays où espace déconstruit
d'avoir à supporter tout seul le poids
de l'accueil des réfugiés clairement
dans le droit international
il y a le devoir d'une solidarité
internationale aujourd'hui on sort un
rapport où andy il y à une crise
mondiale des réfugiés
50 millions de personnes sur terre sont
déplacés 16 millions sont des réfugiés
et on n'a aucune réponse concertée
responsable solidaire de la communauté
internationale chez audi et avez le goût
et l'arabie saoudite le koweït
ils ont beaucoup d'argent et de pétrole
mais il n'en voit que des couvertures ni
rien à faire les couvertures dira biya
il devrait nous prendre ou encore
l'europe
ils sont beaucoup d espace mais c'est
très difficile dit elle
mais le plus dur pourra bien c'est de ne
pouvoir rentrer chez lui vandal radio la
syrie dit-il
c'est ce que nous avons de plus précieux
mais pour le moment il ne peut qu'en
rêver ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada
beyrouth